is this the real life to me I lead our
place is this just fantasy in a
landslide no escape from reality
I want our simple task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet they're
bad guys worst of the worst
was this a cheerleading trial
ah hi boys
good shot guy shoots people he's
crocodile eats people burns people
you're possessed by twitch she's just
crazy what was that I should kill
everyone and escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding that's not what
they really said this is the deal you're
going somewhere very bad do something
don't get killed so save the world
I can't wait to show you my toys let's
do something fun
all
you
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people
you're bad guys it's what we do
it's checking some work but I finally
have them the worst of the worst
we're let's just say I put them in a
hole - away the hole whose rumors Amanda
that some of them have abilities oh yeah
I have seen things maybe Superman was
some kind of beacon for them to creep
back from the shadows
I want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet who
I think can do some good
they're bad guys exactly and if anything
goes wrong we blame them we have
built-in deniability what makes you
think you can control because getting
people to act against their own
self-interest is what I do follow him
Oh
all you need to know is you work for me
so that's it huh with the passes with
some kind of Suicide Squad
so save the world
nice
we got insurance
now they say about the crazy ones huh
oh yeah
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
bad hello young that shots - she slider
yes uncle vertie ref the slaughter never
burned lighter boobies